et bonsoir docteur ne nous on merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
une petite question qui peut peut-être
nationale mais je serai curieuse d'avoir
votre point de vue d' american en france
donc la ministre de la santé qui
démissionne pour se lancer dans une
élection un internat nationale la mairie
de paris en l'occurrence en plein
coronavirus ça vous inspire quoi vous ça
pourrait arriver et ça serait critiquée
non aux états unis un changement de
direction
en période de crise ce n'est pas idéal
et j'espère qu'il ya dans les
fonctionnaires qui sont présents pour
continuer ce travail c'est c'est
vraiment essentiel c'est là que se
trouve l expertise technique et avoir
une personnalité forte et respectée afin
de diriger et d'être le visage public de
la réaction c'est très important
justement c'est intéressant ce que vous
nous dites parce que qu'est ce qui vous
semble vous le plus important tant que
médecin chercheur les pouvoirs publics
ont un rôle extrêmement important à
jouer où il faut plutôt compter sur les
grands organismes comme l'om est ce qu
est ce qui est finalement le plus
important dans ce type de crise les
décisions prises par les pouvoirs
publics sont majeurs
nationale et son nationale sont
essentielles c'est elle qui vont assurer
le travail au niveau des communautés
le ms bien sûr est une ressource
importante mais il s'agit notamment d'un
organisme ne sera pas au coeur des
opérations notamment dans ce cas de
figure où il ya des problèmes à traiter
dans le monde entier n'ont pas
l'impression suffisance autorités de
santé nationales et locales seront donc
en première ligne
alors revenons en aux chiffres au moins
70 1500 cas en chine un peu plus de 1700
wc environ 800 autres cas signalés dans
d'autres pays
quel est votre regard de spécialiste de
médecins sur ces chiffres qu'il ya des
dizaines de milliers de cas rapportés
chaque jour c'est parce que je vois que
dans de nombreux pays les cas ne sont
pas liés à des voyages en chine et qu'on
trouve des cas au sein de la communauté
cela montre que la propagation du virus
est très rapide et très discrète donc il
est très difficile d'essayer de répondre
de réagir en renforçant les frontières
nationales en essayant d'éviter
l'importation du virus dans les pays
aujourd'hui nous devons déjà présumer
que tous les pays sont peuvent être
contaminés et nous devons région que
mettre en place des mesures afin
d'atténuer l'impact du virus à dire et
c'est de protéger les individus qui est
assurée les plus susceptibles à d
maladie quelques les personnes âgées ou
les personnes qui ont des comorbidités
il faut s'assurer que les lits
d'hôpitaux soient réservés aux personnes
qui en auront vraiment besoin et qu'il
ne s'agisse pas simplement un d'isoler
des personnes qui ont des cas bénins
la majorité des cas à ce jour était
assez bénin il faut tout comme
reconcentrer et concentrer nos
ressources limitées sur les personnes
qui risquent plus suite à ce virus
justement on a beaucoup parlé de ce
paquebot un veau ressortissants
américains les croisiéristes sont
finalement rentrés heureusement pour eux
quatorze cas positifs
ils sont d'ailleurs étaient placés en
quarantaine quelle est votre réaction
c'était la bonne décision à prendre
j'ai exprimé mes critiques vis-à-vis de
cette approche
je ne pense pas que cela permettra
d'empêcher l'introduction dû virus
ce genre d'opération laisse à penser
qu'on pourrait échapper au virus mais
c'est impossible et je pense que cela
détourne les ressources publiques du
travail important qui doit être mise en
oeuvre dans les communautés pour mitiger
atténuer l'impact du virus
ce sont les mêmes personnes qui essayent
de soutenir ces personnes encore un teen
devrait en quarantaine devraient
travailler avec les hôpitaux avec
communauté pour se préparer à la
propagation du virus
donc je suis assez inquiète que nous
concentrons nos ressources au mauvais
endroit vous dit elle devrait se
préparer
à lutter contre la propagation du virus
est ce qu'on doit y voir un signe
d'inquiétude de votre part vous craignez
justement une plus grande propagation du
virus les prochaines semaines cela
beaucoup à ce que nous avons vu en 2009
avec la grippe en 2009
une fois comme ça ont vu l'apparition
d'un nouveau virus de la grippe il s'est
répandu dans tout le pays très
rapidement alors qu'on essaie justement
de l'unité de limiter son expansion
je pense que nous devrions ont dissipé
l'été qu'il y aura beaucoup de
propagation fait état de cas et donc ce
sont les pays en fait qu'ils recherchent
le virer ce temps qu'il faut que nous
nous attendions notre surveillance aux
endroits se retrouve véritablement le
virus et nous concentrer sur les
communautés afin de réduire l'impact du
virus et non pas essayer simplement de
l'empêcher de rentrer dans les pays au
niveau des frontières nationales au
canon savons pas où est le virus en ce
moment dans le monde
cela rend une approche géographique très
difficile justement rien des agences de
tourisme qui pointe la baisse de
tourisme en asie chez ces prochains
temps est-ce que vous approuvez ce qu'
il est nécessaire justement pour les
touristes aujourd'hui d'éviter la zone
asiatique selon vous pour lesquels le
voyage est moins populaire c'est
effectivement cette inquiétude vis à vis
du virus
il ya également beaucoup d'incertitude
alors dit s'agissant des réponses au
niveau national personne ne veut voyager
et se retrouve en quarantaine dans un
pays étranger donc l'incertitude
vis-à-vis des réactions nationales ont
aussi un impact sur le tourisme
il faut étudier tous les toutes les
conséquences de ce virus au niveau de la
santé mais également au niveau des
gouvernements qui pourrait prendre des
mesures renforçant l'impact économique
de ce virus
nous ne voulons pas adopter des mesures
qui sont payés pour les pays que le
virus lui-même donc nous devons tous
examiner aujourd'hui certains
observateurs disent qu'on en fait
peut-être un peu trop un nouvel agrippe
finalement tu beaucoup plus de personnes
est ce que vous partagez tous le même
cette analyse est ce qu'il faut à ce
point s'inquiéter le virus pose problème
est ce inquiétant est la raison pour
laquelle ça inquiète chute continue
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup d'inconnues dans
la situation notamment
c'est encore de découvrir de comprendre
la gravité de l'impact de ce virus
effectivement s'il s'agit simplement de
compter les décès c'est déjà assez
inquiétant mais c'est plus important que
toute autre maladie reste un fait mais
je ne pense pas que ces estimations sont
parfaitement exact je pense que tous les
cas qu'il est important de rassembler
plus d'informations pour nous en assurer
le niveau d'attention et et pertinents
c'est une nouvelle situation et il faut
se méfier des possibilités négative il
ya des informations peuvent être
optimiste mais je pense que les gens ne
devraient pas se penser que le niveau
l'attention reflète le risque rapidement
parce que nous arrivons malheureusement
la fin de cette interview le vaccin vous
l'espérez pour quand j'ai entendu
beaucoup d'estimations
on parle de l'automne ou d'un un plus et
malheureusement
axa prend toujours plus de temps qu'on
ne le souhaite 2009 nous avions un
vaccin existe déjà qui était déjà en
place
et pourtant cela prit plein temps depuis
on le soutient pour développer un
nouveau vaccin donc j'espère que toute
cette attention concentrer sur le virus
et dramé je pense pas qu'il faut
s'attendre à un accès rapide
merci beaucoup de jenifer nous d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
reste